i remember when i we got edgar the first
time i really
realized i really liked him
was when i was sitting by
my desk making videos and he i didn't
understand what he wanted he kept like
scratching on my leg i was like okay
maybe he wants food but he really just
wanted to sit on my lap edgar's a very
cuddly dog i would almost say clingy he
loves to cuddle
always
and it's very very sweet good morning
again
it's your day today again
it's your day to vlog
[Music]
oh
i
we gotta wait for your sister to wake up
again she's a little slower to wake up
[Music]
i wanna rub your face mine
yeah
[Applause]
rub your face
i don't got it the vlog is about me
obligatory martial
there's the stretch yeah
guys it's wiki tang come on we gotta
walk
oh
iggy
we're good
they're so confused
maya looks like the hot girlfriend in a
music video when they're under the
sheets
you know what i mean and they're all in
love
yeah
yeah yeah
i guess you just look like a troll i'm
sorry
casual car who's excited
okay
okay
okay
you have no choice
maya's on the first p
edgar's your turn no not on maya
it's so rude of you
he doesn't even want to look at us
you're shy peer regular
he always does that but he never does it
where he peed
[Music]
this will be gone in two seconds
gotta check if there's anything else
okay that's it
give up
we usually feed maya first so she's
pissed off that now i fit edgar first
there you go maya
now i can eat now it's my turn
i think someone's interested in my
breakfast
i am no
no stop
sorry maya
she never sits at me on me
but you know i have food in my hands
oh did she just fart did you hear that
ew thanks maya okay
you're the star not maya come here
she's looking for more food okay come
here
okay don't care
there he is
he's still like is there more food why
does my ass smile like she farted
[Music]
maya wants to lick edgar's ear my loves
to lick edgar's ears
come here
there we go
maya he's here i have him
look
lick him
no she's sucking my brain
so i could get saved by marcie every
time
because maya will not stop licking
edgar's ear she's obsessed with it
so as soon as my set comes
come on eggy
he always uses leaves
to safety yeah
sorry my you lost
the battle is lost
[Music]
my ears are protected
thank you my dear
she's looking mean now what are you
doing
ears give me his ears
his ears
it's so cute
do you want to help us solve the wordle
what would be the first word he would
put in egg
it's not a word
i mean
foods
beggar that was a terrible word
[Laughter]
look at her so cute
she wants his ears
no
you could
no
this is the part of the movie where the
dogs are talking and we don't know what
they're saying
okay all right
oh evil
i'm baby yoda oh
you're so cute
and then i'll see you in lunch because
daddy's got to go to work
[Music]
hey man
we were gone for five minutes
but they're very happy we're back
[Music]
oh
thank you edgar
you got me a present
can i keep it
no you keep it then
all right i got pregnant foreign
it's already finished and we're enjoying
look at this beautiful
what is it
pasta
[Music]
you just hear the grunt of italian pain
so today in case it's not obvious or if
i said it it's edgar's day
it doesn't care hey it's your day which
means this vlog is all about edgar and
we have some fun surprises for you edgar
coming up later
but first we have a bad surprise for you
edgar
it's time for your favorite part of the
day
brushing your teeth
yeah
no
no don't do it
he's like i don't know if i like it i
don't like it
sorry to do this to your head gary in
front of everyone but we have to keep
your teeth healthy
yeah
every day
your stupid teeth
whose breath has gone better
and uh we want you to live a long happy
life right here hmm this is why we do
this
now it's the queen's turn
she is not happy
mine is a little more difficult
especially because her mouth is so tiny
my buddy
he's too much too pissed on you
okay i have to brush
you pewdiepie tortures these dogs don't
don't be so dramatic
i'm gentle
there we go
oh
sorry man
let's give him something maya here's a
treat
there you go
hey gary
okay see
there you go good boy sure
take your treat maya
hey do you not want that delicious
[Music]
she doesn't trust us anymore like we had
to give her pills once and then after
that
she spat it out and she never trusts us
anymore she's just like no this is
poison this is what you eat every day
maya
all right
[Music]
oh and he gets to stay with daddy now
happy day for iggy it's my day it's my
special day i usually stay with my dear
but now a day with theory
help me study japanese again
a squishy that means beautiful which i
am thank you
kiramiku that's what i'm doing i'm
sparkling in greater ring
okay
what is he doing what does he expect
food or something
your presence will come soon again
just be patient he's farting away
look at him so innocently but you can't
just fart it goes straight into my mouth
stop it hmm
look how cute you are
look at you
[Music]
work is done it's flight time edgar
i got a present for you
[Music]
i'm sorry sorry
all right let's try that again partner
yeehaw
you're looking like the wildest pug in
the west
hey
you want to talk are you on a drink
he's got that michael jackson style i
like it there you go come my partner
there you go
damn
you look like you're about to solve some
crimes
well fine
don't worry maya i got you a gift as
well
is her head too tiny cool
it's a little small wait the other one
is bigger i think can you breathe miami
yes
you are so cute
this is the best one sorry edgar you're
not that important anymore
i love it
this is adorable let me look at it
oh sorry
this is so dumb
yeah that's better
hey don't attack her
okay so i got this
i think you're supposed to put stuff in
here and then
oh all right you figure it out
you turn it on somehow
and then
whoa
this is terrorizing him
everything flew out
oh my god that was like the most
expensive toy i got i basically bought
him like the new iphone what is this it
doesn't do nothing there you go
get the toy
what is this
[Music]
so bad
maybe i'm doing it wrong maybe you're
supposed to be bigger are you enjoying
your toy edgar
aka just feeding you watch i'm putting
this in here
so you can figure out
okay it's in the toy it's enjoying
wow
wow the toy is so fun
he got scared
let's try this one
you can adjust
if you have smaller treats
but he also has a small brain so let's
make it big
[Music]
all right hey guys iq test time
how big is your brain
how big is your brain all right we're
setting it to max now how big is your
brain
[Music]
oh
[Music]
something must be going on with that
thing don't you think edgar
oh sh
keep trying that oh
maybe interact with it and see what
happens again
he's thinking really hard
[Music]
oh my god it's magic
how does it work again
i don't get it
the drool
i don't get it i don't get it all right
guys you're not smart enough we're gonna
have to punish you hold up
has he spotted it damn that looks real
[Music]
hey guys
never buying you any toilet
he's like what is that egg
[Music]
this is edgar's favorite thing to do is
try and wrestle me with my finger
and i always win
this is your favorite thing to do right
here
i'm going to show everyone how tough you
are
you want to growl
yeah they're so tough wow
wow you hear that
so evil you're so evil right there
[Music]
yesterday a good day
[Music]
all right it's 11.
that means it's time for bed
and
time for bed
how was your day again
not interesting
you didn't take me on a long walk
oh my akima
[Music]
he likes to play at night he does this
every night where he just like goes a
little psycho
are you a little psychoaggie
are you a demon
did you have a fun day and gay
yeah
very fun thank you toronto
don't look at me i'm so shy
and then you have the potato